We now have some data with which we can evaluate
what Donald Trump's tariffs, which are part
of his trade war, have done to the economy.
Remember the whole point of putting tariffs
on goods from other countries is to make those
goods more expensive so that American people
and businesses will buy local as it were,
switching to American goods from foreign goods.
That's the idea.
The problem is that we depend on cheap foreign
stuff from countries like China, much more
than China.
Depends on us.
So when both countries tariff each other,
which is what we've seen happen, our stuff
gets more expensive.
While China gets stuff from other countries,
to put it simply, this is a vast simplification,
but we're just trying to get caught up so
we can have today's conversation.
The federal reserve, which is run of course
by Donald Trump's fed chairman, has put together
a report.
And what we learned from that report is that
Donald Trump's tariffs led to job losses while
at the same time increasing prices.
Now, if you understand even a little bit about
how tariffs work, this is not a surprise from
day one.
We've been saying this is what's going to
happen.
But alas, a lot of Donald Trump's supporters
denied that this would happen.
So this all started with steel and aluminum
tariffs.
It's grown to many more goods.
The manufacturing sector has been the hardest
hit for sure.
Uh, we've seen, uh, agriculture affected,
it has affected many, many industries.
Now the report does say to be charitable.
This has been the effect so far.
It's hypothetically conceivable that the impact
will reverse in the longer term.
So far it has killed jobs and raised prices.
Maybe at some point it will reverse, but of
course, why would that happen?
It's an obvious question.
There is no coherent explanation for why the
effect would reverse over the longer term.
This is the problem with focusing on principles
and ignoring the real world, and I've talked
about this before.
This is really important for the left to understand
if we want to do well, although it applies
to everybody.
When the tariffs started, you had a lot of
people who were speaking in theoretical economic
terms, so a theoretical economic argument
would be tariffs work because they make foreign
goods more expensive.
That leads to companies using American goods,
which will stimulate our economy and it'll
be bad for China because we'll be pulling
a whole bunch of business away from them and
putting it into domestic businesses.
We should protect our economy with tariffs
would be the theoretical outcome or consequence
or conclusion of that idea.
It's a lovely theory if we're starting economies
from scratch, but we're not, we have an economy
in the United States that's based on cheap
stuff from China.
Manufacturing was moved to China years ago
and other countries, because it was decided
implicitly, I don't mean you decided, but
as a country it was decided by our leaders
that we value the cheap stuff from China more.
Uh, then we would be hurt by higher prices
if we were to keep all manufacturing in the
United States.
Once that's in process, something like a tariff
is not going to have the theoretical effect
that an economics textbook would suggest.
China has more alternatives for their stuff
that they tariffs.
The United States on.
Our economy is based on getting that cheap
stuff from China.
And so then obviously the result is what we're
seeing.
We are seeing job losses combined with higher
prices.
Even economics professors knew this early
on and they said the theoretical impact of
a tariff is not the same as what the real
world impact will be in 2019 United States
and 2019 China.
If those two countries get into a trade war,
this was coming a mile away and it ends up
being a tax on the middle class who can't
afford to pay more for stuff in the context
of stagnant wages and everything else that
we've been discussing.
So what's next?
I don't know.
We may see the way the administration has
been running things we may see even more tariffs.
We will see what 2020 brings, but the results
not at all surprising to anyone who's been
paying attention and reminder, this is the
federal reserve chaired by Donald Trump's
pick that has told us this is what is going
on.
Let me know what you think.
Let let me know if you're surprised, quite
frankly, because it seems as though our audience
basically understood this.
Remember that on January 1st the blowout 2020
membership special will be available.
If you want to be notified about it, it's
really easy.
Just go to David pakman.com sign up for our
newsletter and on January 1st you'll get an
email
with an obscene league, disgustingly cheap
membership offer.
We'll take a quick break.
Follow me on Twitter.
At D Pacman and we'll be right back after
this,